New Jersey Senator Bob Menendez has been
indicted on charges that he took bribes
of cash gold bars and a luxury car for
corrupt purposes including using his
influence over Foreign Affairs to
benefit the Egyptian government
investigators found $100,000 in gold
bars and $480,000 in hidden cash at
menendez's house menendez's wife naen
was also indicted along with three New
Jersey businessmen and perhaps most
surprisingly the charges are unrelated
to the Senator's 2016 criminal case
which ended with a hung jury Menendez is
the first active Senator to be indicted
for two different criminal cases so
congrats on making history again senator
now Menendez has already stepped down as
chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee and his re-election campaign
is now in doubt and now as the time of
this recording roughly half of the
Democrats in the Senate have called for
menendez's resignation now this is a
start contrast the last time that
Menendez was under scrutiny possibly
because there's a Democratic governor of
New Jersey who would appoint menendez's
replacement which wasn't the case last
time uh so today we're going to talk
about how the Supreme Court has made it
harder for the justice department to
prosecute public corruption and just how
Brazen the Menendez corruption
allegations appear to be now as usual
keep in mind that the facts in the
indictment are still allegations and the
government still has to prove its case
and here this is something that the
justice department knows all too well
because Senator Menendez a Democrat has
been in the doj's crosshairs since 2015
when a grand jury indicted him on 14
counts of bribery wire fraud making
false statements and conspiracy over
favors he did for a Florida ey doctor
Solomon melin Menendez to trial for
pressuring the government to resolve a
Medicare billing dispute in melin's
favor securing visas for the doctor's
girlfriends and helping to protect a
contract the doctor had to provide Port
screening equipment to the Dominican
Republic now the government argued a
trial that do melan's gifts and campaign
contributions were part of an agreement
between the men that Menendez would
intercede with government officials for
Dr melan on an as-needed basis over many
years for example prosecutors tried to
demonstrate a connection between a
$60,000 donation to menendez's Legal
defense fund and the uh New Jersey
Democratic State committee and to
request by bendz the same day to meet
with Ambassador William Brownfield about
a cargo contract to dispute involving
melan menendez's defense was that he and
melan were just good friends and as we
all know very good friends uh you know
give each other lavish gifts including
free rides on private jets Menendez did
not initially disclose his private jet
rides on his Senate ethics filings but
he amended them later and this defense
seemed to work for Menendez when his
case went to trial in 2017 jurors were
deadlocked on most counts and the trial
judge finally declared a hung jury and
after the hung jury district judge
William walls granted the defense's
motion for acquittal as to seven of the
18 counts in the indictment the judge
made a distinction between campaign
contributions and other things of value
because the campaign contributions have
increased first amendment protection and
if the bribery involves campaign funds
the government has to prove an explicit
quidd proquo which requires evidence
connecting the quid and the quo Menendez
accepted gifts but the gifts weren't
clearly predicated on political favors
as the argument goes and some of Dr
melan's generosity arguably grew out of
the friendship between the two men the
justice department dismissed the
remaining charges against Menendez but
Dr melan was convicted of 67 counts of
healthcare fraud for stealing $73
million and sentenced to 17 years in
prison however Donald Trump commuted
melan's sentence in 2021 and Menendez is
said to have played a small uh part in
that commutation now several Federal
statutes provide for federal prosecution
of public corruption by elected
officials including Rico the Hobs act
the travel act and bribery mail and wire
fraud statutes Etc now it's always been
challenging to prove bribery and related
crimes because often these crimes happen
in secret back room meetings with a wink
and a nod but proving these crimes is
now a lot harder because of a series of
decisions by the Supreme Court under
Chief Justice John Roberts and we can
start with the 2010 case of Skilling
versus United States where the court
narrowed the definition of ominous
Services fraud under 18 USC 1346 in that
case former Enron CEO Jeffrey Skilling
only defrauded people who had a
fiduciary duty effectively engaging in
self-dealing instead of uh defrauding a
third party and as a result Skilling got
10 years knocked off of his prison
sentence and the federal government saw
its ability to go after public
corruption diminished in the Skilling
case the honest Services statute was
interpreted to apply only to Kickbacks
and bribes and didn't prescribe
undisclosed self-dealing by a public
official or private employee that is the
taking of an official action by the
employee that furthers his own
undisclosed Financial interests while
reporting to act on the interests of
those for whom he has a fiduciary duty
the Roberts Court dealt another blow to
public corruption efforts in its 2016
decision in McDonald versus United
States in that case the court reversed a
corrupt conviction of the former
governor of Virginia Bob McDonald who
had accepted gifts from a political
donor who wanted to do business with the
state including
$175,000 clothing a Ferrari and Rolex
the Supreme Court vacated the
convictions because McDonald's actions
were not considered official acts under
the statutory definition of that term in
the McDonald case Johnny Williams was
the owner of a Virginia company called
star scientific which was developing a
supplement called anat block uh star
scientific used to be a cigarette
company but in 2012 it rebranded himself
as a technology innovator promoting a
dietary supplement containing tobacco I
mean just straight out of The Simpsons
Williams met McDonald during his
re-election campaign for governor of
Virginia Williams pitched his tobacco
supplement to McDonald expressing his
desire that public universities get
research grants to study all the
benefits of anat block McDonald
introduced Williams to Virginia
Secretary of Health and Human Resources
a couple months later McDonald's wife
Moren suggested that Williams sit with
her at a campaign rally and as a thank
you Williams purchased her $20,000 worth
of clothing the McDonald's and William
then met at the governor's mansion to
discuss the parameters of research
studies Governor McDonald and his wife
were having some serious money problems
at the time Moren told Williams that her
husband had a message for him it's okay
for me to help you but I need you to
help me Williams got the message and
gave the couple $65,000 and McDonald set
up meetings for Williams with state
agencies Williams let the McDonald's use
his vacation house and drive his Ferrari
when Moren suggested that her husband
would really like a Rolex Governor
McDonald got a a Rolex and the governor
delivered on his promises to help
Williams in 2011 he set up a lunch with
University researchers and Williams with
a goal of launching an an block
McDonald's spoke to the researchers
about the scientific validity of the
supplement whether or not there was any
reason to explore this further and if it
might be something good for the
Commonwealth Governor McDonald then
asked for a $50,000 loan Moren McDonald
emailed her husband's counsil urging
them to get this going and the governor
held a second reception for the
University researchers McDonald even
suggested that Virginia offer an out of
block on the state's employee healthcare
plan CL Williams then gave the
McDonald's another loan and took them on
a vacation Federal prosecutors indicted
McDonald in 2014 for Honor Services
fraud and extortion under the Hobs act
now the biggest issue was whether McDon
received anything of value in return for
being influenced in the performance of
an official act the bribery statute
defines an official act as quote any
decision or action on any question
matter cause suit proceeding or
controversy which may at any time be
pending or which may by law be brought
before any public official in such
officials official capacity or in such
officials place of trust or profit uh
the Supreme Court overturned McDonald's
conviction writing the quote in the
government's view official act
specifically includes arranging a
meeting contacting other public official
or hosting an event without more
concerning any subject including a broad
policy issue such as Virginia's economic
development but the Supreme Court said
that that was simply too broad it could
stifle all uh constituent services and
and chill the actions of politicians
though to be fair to the government's
position the statute literally uses the
word any several times and the plain
text of the statute doesn't include any
limiting language but the Supreme Court
canw the words question and matter
narrowly according to the court for the
government to prove its case there
needed to be something more before an
event meeting or speech related to a
pending question or matter became an
official decision or action the court
said that the something more could be
McDonald taking action or making a
decision on a qualifying step toward an
official act using an official position
to exert pressure on another official to
perform an official act or providing
advice to another official knowing or
intending that such advice would form
the basis uh for an official act by
another official but the Supreme Court
made a distinction between simply
expressing support and exerting pressure
on another government official and the
court decided that setting up these
meetings where Williams could push a
supplement was not really an official
decision or action so the court
overturned the conviction and remanded
the case to the fourth circuit to decide
whether McDonald's other actions were
official acts under the new definition
and the justice department uh
specifically a prosecutor known as Jack
Smith elected to drop the case now
obviously based on all this Senator
Menendez is going to need a good lawyer
but if you want a great lawyer my firm
the eagle team can help if you've been
in a car crash suffered a data breach or
have a workers's comp issue we can
represent you or help find you the right
attorney who can now it's important to
talk to a lawyer right away so you can
get the best representation so just
click on link in the description for a
free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team the link is down
below now back to menendez's corruption
and the McDonald case has had a profound
tangible impact on public corruption
charges after McDonald criminal charges
were dismissed against Dean skelos the
former New York Senate Majority Leader
Sheldon silver the former New York
assembly speaker and William Jefferson a
Louisiana congressman who stored $90,000
worth of bribe money in his office
freezer and in 2020 the Supreme Court
dismissed charges against two aids to
former New Jersey Governor Chris
Christie over the bridg gates Scandal
and in 2022 the court overturned the
conviction of Joseph pcoo in Aid to New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo pcoo took
$35,000 in exchange for helping to
facilitate a real estate development so
you can see that these decisions made it
much much harder to go after public
bribery and so why would the government
pursue charges against Bob Menendez now
well because menendez's alleged conduct
which started less than a year after he
escaped conviction on bribery charges
which is so Brazen that prosecutors
think that they can prove their case and
it's one of the reasons that they are
charging him with a bunch of crimes that
are not actual bribery itself but things
related to bribery now the menz
indictment names four codefendants his
wife naen will Hannah Jose urbe and Fred
divis Menendez started dating naen
Arslanian immediately after he won his
earlier corrupt rtion case he proposed
to her after a year of dating by singing
a song from the greatest showman uh and
I regret to inform you that we have
video
footage sh of thousand Spotlight the
Indi says that while they were dating
Nadine introduced Menendez to WIIL
Hannah who she had known for years when
the couple met naden was apparently
unemployed wil hanana had been an import
export guy with Egypt and a friend of
nines for a long time but we don't know
many details about their connection the
FBI discovered thousands of text
messages between Hannah and naen on
Hannah's phone shortly after she told
Hannah that she was dating Menendez the
two got to work introducing the senator
to Egyptian officials Hannah also
connected naen with Jose urbe a New
Jersey businessman who already had a
fraud conviction Menendez also had a
relationship with the other defendant
Fred dyis a real estate developer in
2018 the feds charged dbis with
obtaining loans under false pretenses
from a bank that he founded divus is one
of menendez's top fundraisers the
indictment alleged is that the couple
accepted hundreds of thousands of
dollars of bribes in exchange for using
mandez's power and influence as a
senator to seek to protect and enrich
Hannah yube and divis and to benefit the
Arab Republic of Egypt those bribes
included Cash Gold payments for Home
Mortgage compensation for low or no-
show job a luxury vehicle and other
things of value in June of 2022 the FBI
executed a search warant on menendez's
home over $480,000 in cash much of it
stuffed into envelopes and hidden in
clothing closets and
was discovered in the home along with
over $70,000 in naen menendez's safe
deposit box some of the envelopes
contain the fingerprints and or DNA of
dbus or his driver other cash was found
on jackets actually bearing the name
Senator Bob Menendez as you can see in
that photograph the search also turned
up gold bars the ignment alleges that
Menendez took a series of official acts
to benefit the Egyptian government and
enrich his codefendants Menendez was
then the ranking member of the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee and
subsequently became the chair chair now
the status gave him influence over the
Executive Branch's decisions to provide
foreign military sales foreign military
financing and other Aid or support uh
for the benefit of the government of
Egypt and here's just one example of a
potential quidd proquo in exchange for
promising to use his power and authority
to facilitate weapon sales and financing
to Egypt Hannah promised among other
things to put nen Menendez on the
payroll of his company in a low or no-
show job and apparently menendez's help
went well beyond advocating for more
military aid for Egypt he actually
promised to get nonpublic information
regarding the number and nationality of
people who worked at the US Embassy in
Cairo quote although this information
was not classified it was deemed highly
sensitive because it could pose
significant operational security
concerns if disclosed to a foreign
government or if made public Menendez
obtained the information and then
without telling his professional staff
his Senate colleagues or the state
department that he was doing so texted
that information to naen and here's that
text message just FYI a number of
Americans accommodation of diplomats
commercial service us usaid other number
of Egyptians locally employed staff this
is what's at American Embassy then
summary of ratio are Egyptians working
at Embassy and this is incredibly
serious because he potentially revealed
the identities of people who might have
been working Counter Intelligence under
diplomatic cover they Menendez passed
that information to Hannah who passed it
along to an Egyptian official later in
May of 2018 Menendez had dinner with
Hannah and gave him non-public
information about military aid to Egypt
prompting Hannah to text an Egyptian
official the following information quote
the ban on small arms and ammunition to
Egypt has been lifted that means sailes
can begin this will include sniper
rifles among other articles now it
should be noted that the government of
Egypt is known as being relatively
authoritarian with a poor human rights
record though Menendez might argue that
he wasn't alone in trying to push aid
for Egypt at the time that these events
went down president Trump had expressed
support for president abdal fatah alisi
who was seeking the power to remain in
office until 2034 and other Senators
obviously agreed with the military
package but Menendez was the chairman of
the Foreign Relations Committee and he
was allegedly acting in secret without
notifying his colleagues and his
activities on behalf of the Egyptian
government included ghost writing a
letter seeking to convince other
Senators to lift a hold on $300 million
to Egypt and here's an example of mandez
flexing his power as chair after meeting
with Egyptian officials and naen uh
Menendez texted naen quote tell Will I
am going to sign off in the sale to
Egypt today Egypt
46,0 mm target practice rounds and
10,000 rounds tank am
99 million note these tank rounds are
for tanks they have had for many years
they are using these in the Sinai for
the counterterrorism campaign now in the
McDonald case the Supreme Court ruled
the prosecutors can't demonstrate
official acts just through chronology
alone however there are several
instances where there appear to be a
very close Nexus between menendez's Act
and the payments for example he gave
naen quote a copy of a news article
reporting on questions that other US
senators intended to ask Egyptian
officials five regarding a human rights
issue a few days later Menendez met with
the Egyptian official and 2 days after
the trial Hannah purchased 22 1 o gold
bars each with a unique serial number
two of these 1 o Gold Bars were
subsequently found during the court
authorized search in June 2022 with the
residents of Menendez and naen Menendez
so that's an instance of Menendez
helping to prepare an Egyptian official
to answer questions from his colleagues
and then being rewarded quickly possibly
with actual gold bars and Menendez can't
really use the friend defense on this
one either and this isn't Justice Thomas
hanging out with his wealthy friend on a
luxury yacht Menendez was accepting gold
bars and hiding them in his clothes and
another problem for Menendez is that his
wife seemed to be pretty bold in asking
for money when a news article reported
the US government would send $2.5
billion in military aid to Egypt Nan
allegedly sought a kickback she
forwarded a link to the news article to
Hannah writing Bob had to sign off on
this the indictment says that Hannah
yube and divis uh complied with her
request by giving the couple hundreds of
thousands of dollars in checks cash and
gold some of which was recovered during
the June 2022 search Nadine also
allegedly sold some of the gold in
Manhattan prior to the search and
deposited the proceeds into bank
accounts she controlled it also appears
that Menendez helped his codefendants
monopolize the Egyptian market for
certifying imported halal meat
apparently all Egyptian meat must be
certified as Halal meaning that it has
been procured stored and shipped in
accordance with Islamic law and
obtaining this certificate is a crucial
requirement for meat suppliers to be
able to access the lucrative Egyptian
market and until 2019 American exporters
were generally able to meet these
conditions and bring their products to
the Egyptian Market however in May of
that year the Egyptian agriculture
Ministry disqualified all hillal
certificates eligible to operate in the
United States except for one newly
licensed company iseg Halal certified 5
months later the ministry awarded the
same company exclusive certification
rights in South America as well a major
source of Egypt's imported meat now iseg
Halal is owned by none other than will
Hannah so the government of Egypt
granted Hannah an exclusive Monopoly
even though neither Hannah or his
company had experience with Halal
certification and the indictment alleges
that naen and Bob formed an LLC to
receive bribe payments for their actions
upon nen's marriage to Senator Menendez
Hana gave nen a lucrative synic here at
the time hana's company wasn't doing
very well but when he brought naen on
board he suddenly wound up with an
exclusive contract to export halal meat
to Egypt tell you this no show is
tough deciding what not to wear to work
what not to put in my lunch box uh when
the Egyptian government gave Hana the
Monopoly nting texted her husband it
seems like Halal went through it might
be a fantastic 2019 all the way around
apparently nine told a family member
about this Arrangement texting that
quote every time I'm in a middle person
for a deal I'm asking to get paid and
this is my consulting company seems like
a pretty clear way of describing a
kickback and prosecutors I'm sure will
be eager to show the text messages to
the jury the indictment says Hana used
the proceeds from the Monopoly to fund
bribes the implication here is that the
Egyptian government might have come up
with a way to help Hana to get even
closer to Menendez and it appears that
officials from the US Department of
Agriculture objected to the Monopoly but
Mendez intervened to defend iseg Halal
when a USDA official tried to explain
that the Monopoly was detrimental to us
interests Menendez demanded that the
USDA stay out of it and Hannah ybe and
dbus made sure that Bob and naen were
paid for their efforts Hannah paid nen's
mortgage when the house went into
foreclosure in 2019 uh when the men
delayed their monthly payments to the
LLC nen pestered them about not
delivering the envelopes uh that
contained money obviously in a timely
manner and eventually iseg Halal issued
three $10,000 checks to the LLC and this
appears to be another reason that the
doj chose to go after Menendez the money
was going straight into an LLC in their
name rather than into a campaign account
or disguise through shell companies so
if true this is just you know really
sloppy corruption now Fred dbus
reportedly has ties to the genevese
family in New Jersey in 2020 the feds
were Prosecuting him for an Insider loan
scam tied to his bank Menendez recommend
commended President Joe Biden appoint a
prosecutor who he believed would be more
sympathetic to Menendez and that nominee
appears to be the current US attorney
for New Jersey Philip Selinger Selinger
eventually recused himself from the dbus
case uh dbus and his driver allegedly
delivered envelopes with thousands of
dollars in cash to menendez's home now a
few days later the indictment says
Menendez allegedly conducted a Google
search for kilo of gold price then nen
brought two kilo gold bars to be
appraised by a jeweler the indictment
says that she lied and said she obtained
the bars from her mother when in reality
the gold bars had serial numbers showing
that they were purchased by divis and
Menendez also appears to have tried to
intervene in a state prosecution of one
of ure's relatives and in exchange for
his actions Nadine received a
mercedesbenz and the government might
have a slightly stronger case with
respect to the ways that Menendez
intervene in state criminal prosecutions
the indictment alleges that Menendez did
things that he hoped would resolve the
prosecutions in favor of his
codefendants he met with a candidate for
federal prosecutor and rais the
prospects of dropping the divus
prosecution when that candidate said he
would have to accuse himself from that
prosecution Menendez decided not to
recommend that candidate to Biden Mendez
then recommended that President Biden
appoint another candidate for federal
prosecutor who Menendez believed would
be favorable for divis but the
indictment doesn't say that Menendez
asked any government official to
actually drop the charges although the
prosecutor got the appointment he then
recused himself from the case and
Menendez complained about this recusal
and asked his advisor to look into it
divus then awarded Mendez with money and
gold bars the Indi also charges Menendez
with interfering with a State
prosecution this time on behalf of an
associate of urbe at the time n Menendez
was involved in a car accident and Hana
and yure allegedly gave her a car in
exchange for help with a criminal case
they all had dinner and a few days later
the senator called the state official
and quote spoke with him and an attempt
through advice and pressure to cause a
resolution of the prosecution in the New
Jersey defendant's favor the indictment
says the New Jersey official ignored
menendez's comments and did not
intervene in the matter and did not talk
with the prosecution team about Menendez
uh but the indictment contains a curious
allegation quote nonetheless in or about
April 2019 the New Jersey defendant
resolved his criminal prosecution with a
guilty plea pursuant to a plea agreement
that recommended a non- incarcerator
sentence this resolution was more
favorable to the New Jersey defendant
than the prosecutor's initial plea offer
earlier in the case so the defendant got
a favorable deal but prosecutors never
talked with Menendez nor did they know
that Menendez inquired about the case
that's curious so the McDonald case
certainly complicates the government's
effort to prove that menendez's
activities were official Acts within the
meaning of the Supreme Court's
interpretation of the law however I'm
sure Menendez will argue that he was
simply expressing support for Egypt and
not directly intervening on any matter
before the government and the government
also has to prove that the money and
Gifts were actually given in exchange
for menendez's actions which is always a
hard thing to prove now Menendez is
charged with conspiracy to commit
bribery conspiracy to commit honest
Services fraud and conspiracy to commit
extortion under color of official right
now all public corruption prosecutions
involve proving that a public official
performed an official act and courts
turn to the official Act definition in
the bribery statute section 201 A3 as
discussed above count number two
involves a conspiracy to commit honest
Services fraud an honest Services fraud
is defined in federal statute 18 USC
1346 as a scheme to defraud another of
the intangible right to honor Services
there were schemed to violate a
fiduciary duty or by bribery or
kickbacks and that section was in the
news during the Felicity Huffman
cheating scandal when coaches parents
and students were involved in a
conspiracy to cheat on college entrance
exams count three is a conspiracy to
commit EXT under color of official right
in violation of 18 USC 1951 which is
known as the Hobbs act not surprisingly
the government is asking for forfeiture
of all property that's traceable to the
alleged offenses including $486,000 in
US currency seized from the family home
$79,000 taken from a safe deposit box 13
gold bars all money held by the LLC and
the Mercedes-Benz Menendez faces up to
45 years in prison but his actual
sentence would probably be a lot shorter
on court one Menendez faces 151 to 188
months uh in prison in under the federal
guidelines his overall base offense
level of 14 would be adjusted up because
of the total amount of brmes is over
$550,000 he'd also get four more points
for being an elected official it's also
possible the offense level would be
adjusted two points up for obstructing
or impeding investigation by deleting
text messages but it's not entirely
clear whether there was obstruction here
since we don't know if Menendez knew
that there was an investigation when he
deleted the messages Menendez denies
wrongdoing and says he's being
prosecuted because of his race he claims
the money found in his home was from his
personal savings account and that he
frequently withdraws cash because his
family's possessions were confiscated
during Castro's revolution in Cuba
despite the fact that he was born in the
United States he did not come up with a
reason why he had multiple gold bars in
his house it's reported that the FBI is
investigating whether Egypt's
intelligence Services might have been
involved in the alleged bribery scheme
this could lead to more charges against
Menendez the Scandal has National
Security implications so I'm going to
need a good cup of coffee to keep up
with all these corruption allegations
which I can get with today's sponsor
Trade coffee trade's great because not
only they have a huge selection of your
favorite coffees but they have a
fine-tune matching process that helps
you discover fresh coffee based on your
taste preferences I have very specific
tastes in coffee I basically want
something that tastes like hot chocolate
and pairs well with milk and trade was
able to find me the perfect beam and
let's be honest you claim to want a rich
dark roast but you really want a coffee
milkshake and that's okay but either way
trade has you covered they also have a
huge selection of cold bruise but now
that the weather is getting colder you
probably want a piping hot cup of joe
which trade is perfect for and with
trade you can discover new coffees from
the nation's top Roasters you choose
your coffee rate and your coffee
suggestions get better over time all
conveniently delivered straight to your
door it's really the best coffee website
out there and if you already know what
you like then they probably already have
your rooster in stock at a great price
you can even choose whole beans or your
preferred grind so if you're a coffee
drinker or know someone who is
definitely give trade a try legal
eaglets will get their first bag free
when they sign up all you have to do is
click on the link in the description or
the one that's on screen right now and
not only will you get one bag free but
you'll also get free shipping so get
your first bag by clicking on the link
that's on screen right now or down below
after that click on this link over here
for more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court